cannabis
arguably the most controversial plant in
history
we must wage total war against Public
Enemy Number One the problem of
dangerous drugs in 1971 the penalties
for pot equaled heroin under the federal
Controlled Substances Act this plant can
do so much for society if we allow it it
interferes with your short-term memory
what's happened from happening is the
government propaganda was strong just
say no but today many states just say
yes marijuana is now legal
[Applause]
for many this division between state and
federal laws creates a big problem we
had in 2019 more marijuana arrests in
all violent crime arrests combined too
many lives have been upended because of
our failed approach to marijuana
cannabis is already a big business
as long as there is high market demand
there is always going to be Supply
the older cat's been doing this for 20
or 30 years want to be part of society
this isn't Cheech and Chong's weed this
is in 1969 weed this is real intentional
business
we're creating industry here
[Music]
at the start of the medical marijuana
green rush in California National
Geographic was there talking to new and
old entrepreneurs
all ready to cash in
I feel like I was at home
we all had aspirations that this was
going to be this is going to become
legal we were gonna do this right so the
economics are there in today's market
for the grower to be able to afford you
know 60 70 80. the floodgates opened
compelling many business owners to step
out of the quote Legacy Market into the
world of legal Commerce
then came The Regulators
it's been a lot tougher than I ever
thought it would be costs that are
associated with running a legitimate
business are way more than they are
running an illegitimate business
cannabis businesses they're paying about
80 percent of their revenue to taxes
which basically means you can't make
money
with right now is over regulation over
taxation
killing anyone that has a legal license
many of those legal licenses were
granted over a decade ago to Growers
looking to make their fortune in what's
known as California's Emerald Triangle
[Music]
a geographic area made up of three
counties
Humboldt Trinity
and Mendocino
[Music]
the Emerald Triangle is and was the
largest cannabis producing region in the
United States
I've been growing marijuana for 36 years
in the industry up here on the outdoor
grew in the shadows because there was a
strong law enforcement presence
most of the people in these mountains
the older cat's been doing this for 20
or 30 years
they're tired they've been Black Sheep
they've been ostracized they want to
come out and be political they want to
speak their pieces they want to feel
good about themselves I want to be part
of society they never want to leave in
the first place we got the headband
right there we got some cherry Pine to
the side we got blue dream back here
we've got some purple urkles
we've got Mr Nice along with Tim's legal
status came the need to prove his
organic growing practices sit down with
Charlie I'd like to see his final tally
on the amount of medical cannabis that
you were able to produce this year
this is the sweet and sour without the
cherry pie in it I see the different
smell so this is uh this is a much
different smell than the Cherry Pie down
there just as he would with organic
fruits and vegetables Chris Van Hook
inspects marijuana plants for
contaminants mold and mildew and
verifies organic growing methods
[Music]
a very very light pest damage what that
tells me is that you're not spraying a
heavy synthetic pesticide When I'm Gone
this is a real agricultural industry
whether we want to believe it or not
this is the biggest growth field in
America so there's a place for them to
go
every business in Mendocino would be
gone without cannabis
California was the first to legalize
medical marijuana
and for Tim that meant it was time to
stoke the competition
I'd like to welcome everybody to our
seventh annual Emerald cup
Tim co-founded a Grower's event
marijuana Style
it took off
[Music]
I have back problems the path to
legalization in the United States began
in 1996. that's when California voters
rebelled against federal marijuana
prohibition by passing the nation's
first medical marijuana law proposition
215. how hard is it to get as the smoke
laughs here at some
you know I won't say that nobody is
refused but let's just say that
everybody who
needs the protection of of prop 215
deserves to be protected
have you ever turned somebody down for a
recommendation I'm asked that sometimes
and I would have to say
no
that I'm proud of it
foreign
in the early days of the cup fearful of
prosecution Growers and users were
afraid to show their faces
not anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
as marijuana became more legit the
competition grew as a celebration of the
plant
good
[Music]
the Cannabis farmers of the Emerald
Triangle created a community of skilled
Growers
craft commodity
and a way of life
today the emerald cup is still going
strong 19 years and counting and Tim
Blake remains at the helm
much of the weed grown by Emerald
Triangle Farmers made its way to
Statewide medical marijuana dispensaries
places like Harborside Medical Center
National Geographic first met long-time
marijuana activist Steve D'Angelo over a
decade ago
he was one of the first to become a
licensed medical marijuana seller in
California
[Music]
Oakland was Ground Zero for legal
medical cannabis
[Music]
granddaddy purple cross
yeah definitely really fast okay so
we're here at the front door of
Harborside Health Center and three
different kinds of people will come
through that door new patients returning
patients and patients who are bringing
us medicine
it didn't take long for business to Boom
Ah that's really really beautiful we are
on the main dispensary floor of
Harborside Health Center
this is where patients come to view the
different types of medicine that we have
available and make their selections
Harborside was one of the highest
business taxpayers in Oakland
time their annual sales were 21 million
dollars
paying over 2 million dollars to state
sales taxes
D'Angelo became a fixture in marijuana
culture speaking with almost Evangelical
fervor about the plant
with the bullish enthusiasm of a Wall
Street Banker
he took his story on the road to share
the wisdom with a new crop of investors
men and women were eager to get on board
with growing and expanding medical
cannabis laws and all the financial
possibilities
[Music]
we're Publishers medical marijuana
magazines around the country when we
started doing this about 18 months ago
we were really a throwaway magazine and
dispensaries were now distributed in
7-Elevens and a lot of the supermarkets
and people basically line up they know
our distributed distribution dates the
Silvery magazine they wait for the
magazine
we've become one of the leading
providers of insurance the medical
marijuana industry
it's a great business it's it's
unbelievable quite frankly it is it's
moving at a million miles an hour right
now
it looks like it could be a very
profitable business I mean once you get
around the whole federal law
um problem but you know I think you get
the right investors you'll you can make
some money
Wall Street investors analysts Insurance
Brokers entrepreneurs
they all were lured here by the power of
the profit motive I'm a retired
entrepreneur and I see this as probably
the great next new frontier economically
and I think it's kind of like opening a
still about two years before prohibition
is repealed it would be it'd be kind of
a fool not too actually all right great
well but thanks I like that a lot but
still I
after 37 years as an activist I can tell
you that we have come a long long way
and it feels really good to be in this
room so thank you
I think it is the great hope of the
medical cannabis industry that every day
that goes by
every month that goes by without Federal
intervention
this industry grows
number of people entering it increases
the number of transactions increases the
number of state regulations increases
and that it becomes increasingly
difficult for the feds to come and stop
at all living the dreams
but for many entrepreneurs living the
dream quickly turned into a nightmare
prison time aside
federal laws hinder everything from
banking
to Interstate shipping to attracting
very big investors
[Music]
still that wasn't enough to deter former
Wall Street investment banker Derek
Peterson at his business partner Darman
they were about to up the ante by trying
to sell their cannabis Supply Company we
grow to Wall Street we'll contribute
where you can
Derek was on familiar Turf Darr was new
to High Finance
but they were both eager to ring the
Cannabis Bell we're going to put a line
on the board you know pros and cons and
we're gonna start hammering it out
Derek Peterson and Dora Mann met with
investment bankers in 2011. to raise
money for their cannabis startup and try
to take the private company public
so the point of getting everybody in the
same room today
you know we're trying to determine
whether IPO makes the most sense and
we're trying to determine whether
reverse merger makes the most sense do
we all agree that an IPO is going to be
a minimum of six months six months to a
year yeah right I think we're all
favorable of speed here I mean that's
without a question but at what cost do
we have speed our backers are mainstream
Wall Street types but they're not coming
through the entities that they're
involved with
they're interested but they can't get
the the approval through their board to
invest in medical cannabis related
business you know and what's it going to
cost Derek called me and he goes I'm
starting a new company and I need to
raise some funds I thought he was crazy
first because I don't smoke marijuana
but we all know there's money in it I
wanted to learn more and this is an
industry start for cash even Banks won't
take dispensary deposits the federal
illegality of medical cannabis is our
window of opportunity let's just run
through the timeline it gives us an
opportunity to come in without having
you know the Home Depots of the world
come in from a distribution Machinery
standpoint without having to filler
morses of the world come in from a
cultivating and distribution standpoint
we have an opportunity here and that's
what's creating the opportunity for us
and I think that'll put us years ahead
of the competition because no one's
going to have a currency uh that's
actually going to be making money as far
as at the end of the day money motivates
a lot of people and I would be lying if
I said that it does not motivate me I'm
in it for the money and only the money I
want my clients to make money on this
and and this is a great opportunity to
do it I could care less if the roads
fall apart I want my clients to make
money
I'm not quite sure I know any other
agriculture products that you can sell
for 3 500 per pound
Perhaps Perhaps truffles
but I'm not an expert in truffles what
kind of valuation let's just just so I
want to hear some numbers before okay so
let's we get to a run rate
run rates reverse mergers IPOs this was
not the traditional language of
marijuana activism you know and What's
it gonna cost
only getting involved in the industry
because they want to make a lot of money
are premature
let's remember it's a psychoactive
substance
I don't think that we're going to win
the trust of our fellow citizens by
coming in and saying we just want to
treat cannabis like any other commodity
we want to have ads for the Super Bowl
we want it to be in the 7-Elevens we
want it to be just like any other
product I don't think that Americans are
going to go for that all cards on the
table right yeah it was definitely a
concern from Old Guard to new guard
they see us as a threat no disrespect to
them but they tipped the the Domino if
you will and to have an expectation that
other dominoes aren't going to you know
fall as naive
ultimately the Old Guard activists were
right
us
Wall Street wasn't quite ready for
cannabis the commodity
this happy scene was short-lived their
business marriage ended in an ugly
divorce
complete with a flurry of lawsuits each
accusing the other a fraud among other
charges
there continues to navigate the weed
business through different companies
Dar pleaded no contest to defrauding
Oakland and is now a social media
influencer
oh
today's entrepreneurs have the benefit
of hindsight
they also got a boost from the federal
government when the United States passed
the 2018 Farm Bill
the bill among other things made the
non-psychoactive compound known as
cannabinoid or CBD legal for use in
health and medical products
proponents of both CBD and its
intoxicating cousin THC tout their
medical benefits
but for now the way for CBD is much
clearer
the 2018 farm bill just gave a clear
definitive marker between hemp CBD and
cannabis THC it cleaned up a lot of the
gray area and ambiguity and the
difference between hemp and cannabis I'm
a business leader
Reuben entered the legal cannabis
industry in 2015 and I was thinking weed
I'm going to be able to work in weed and
not get in trouble
I started out as an advisor to an
investor and then moved into CEO role
which made me one of the first
African-American CEOs of a major
cannabis company I got to go to
conferences and really see what was
missing in this industry
I started speaking up about what we're
experiencing what we're seeing why we're
seeing it and what the differences were
20 years ago to today right this
industry is still immature 20 years
later the industry's growing pains are
largely due to the conflict between
state and federal law in 37 States plus
the District of Columbia medical use is
legal out of those 21 allow recreational
use
but as far as the federal government is
concerned none of it is legal
there is high market demand as long as
that demand continues to exist there is
always going to be Supply
we've seen that attempts to wipe out
that Supply under prohibition have
failed attempts to completely move that
Supply into the regulated market have so
far failed as well
a fact that keeps business owners like
Ruben in a state of uncertainty
once the federal government understands
how they get their pound of Flesh and
they can become willing participants I
think that this industry in this country
will be a beautiful thing
while State cannabis laws change with
the times federal marijuana prohibition
keeps law enforcement busy
California still loses ground to illegal
marijuana grown by Outlaw farmers
the vast majority of pot sales are still
Underground
where there are no taxes and regulations
secure this trailer Mendo and probation
Will secure this trailer and then we'll
have uh because you guys have four right
we'll have you guys work your way and
secure the garden okay okay and then
once in Mendocino Federal and local law
enforcement were preparing to raid an
illegal Farm
don't cut anything until I talk to these
people
when I first started in the uh early 90s
a good year was 60 000 plants and now
we're over six hundred thousand so it's
just this exploded it's just the main
thing is be safe and uh everybody's
coming here to grow marijuana whether
it's the Mexican Nationals and the
cartels
or the people who are growing for
commercial use
you know we're overwhelmed any questions
at Harvest Time a small army of federal
state and local Law Enforcement Officers
deploy
[Music]
all right everybody
round two today
the plants out here are a bit bigger
than what we had yesterday morning
we're going to take our time
and do a good job get in get it out
safely
no questions
all right let's get going
[Music]
to cut them up
The Growers are just like one grain of
sand on the beach you know there's so
many of them that there's really no risk
for a lot of The Growers
[Music]
here we have marijuana plants that are
growing obviously you could see the
immense size of these plants
I'm five foot nine
and these plants are obviously what
about
12 foot tall 10 12 foot tall
these plants are monstrously big
holy cow
so we have here as you can see marijuana
you know these are basically different
variations of strands this one is
labeled Danny DeVito
this entire residence is set up to be
nothing more than a commercial marijuana
growing operation
to combat illegal Farms the county
officials came up with a plan
to issue permits with no threat of
arrest
I like the haircut man that's right
for me
County ordinance 931 was created to give
medical marijuana growers a legal limit
pay the fee stick to the 99 plan maximum
and the local sheriff leaves your
product alone
we're intending to draw a bright line in
Mendocino County between legal and maybe
legal and the difference there is legal
where the sheriff is issuing a permit
because you're not harming the
environment you're not creating
neighborhood community problems that's
pretty much gold plated it may be legal
you go tell it to the judge the only
real solution is to end Federal
prohibition
going to the 99 plant permit is really
just recognition of reality that
marijuana is here it's not going away
you can pass any law you want people
will ignore that law in the pursuit of
profit prior to July when this program
started what I knew about marijuana was
chop it down alternative okay so I've
learned a lot Sergeant Randy Johnson of
the Mendocino Sheriff's Department ran
the 931 program so we pay you with the
broad brush do you paint us with a broad
brush I realize that as part of the way
it works
I've met a new group of people here I've
told them if we work together I'm not
here to try to shut you down you need to
not be here to try to grow as many
plants as you can grow we need to work
together if you want this to be
successful we learned an awful lot about
law enforcement the most important thing
we learned was we could trust the
Mendocino County Sheriff's Department
thank you that everything you said you
would do you did
thank you
Mendocino County was in the midst of a
budget crisis when Sergeant Randy
Johnson first made his appeal to
marijuana Farmers we have the potential
of seven deputies
absolutely okay
that's how dire the budget is
so you know what I did I said please
hold off because we're going to pay for
some of those guys with this program
is going to be the new money this
here's your seven deputies
so Sergeant Johnson hoped to enroll 150
growers in the 931 program and pay for
new deputies with the fees
what look just let me ask you this if
this program
pays for seven deputies
what what kind of press implications do
you think that's going to be awesome
thank you totally awesome so do you
think that's going to move more in your
favor of getting stuff legalized do you
think other counties are going to be
recognizing this well I think they're
going to have no problem getting your
150 and probably twice or three times
that amount because people are now
realizing that it's time to come in from
the rain and get in here and be
illegally and do it right
I check in with sheriff and you know
what the sheriff trusts me he goes I
don't know what you're doing but these
people love you are you kidding me I'm
getting them from it to grow marijuana
with his Emerald cup as a direct line to
the Region's Growers Tim Blake took the
opportunity to spread the word about the
program and bring greater legitimacy to
their industry are they going to be
inside the law or they're going to be
outside the law and that line is
becoming more defined as we go there are
seven Sheriff's jobs that are being lost
for a sign of 150 people with the intent
to grow we can all likely save all those
jobs we can be the heroes for these
mountains for the law enforcement we can
show that we really are working together
and we can make this happen
and you guys are all welcome to be part
of that part of this 9.31 program and
part of growing legal environmentally
correct cannabis
[Applause]
the program was short-lived as new
Statewide regulations permitting
large-scale agricultural cannabis
cultivation became law which left
smaller Growers who benefited from the
931 program out in the cold
even as rules and regulations shifted
medical marijuana grower Matt Cohen was
just trying to stay legal
and he learned there's a price to pay
for going legit
any legitimate business out there has to
deal with a whole raft of regulations
and Reporting everything it's been a lot
tougher than I ever thought it would be
so we have plenty of building department
wheelchair accessibility issues we're
dealing with I have human resources
issues with employees threatening to you
know sue if they get fired you know we
have workman's comp costs Insurance
costs payroll taxes sales taxes District
taxes it goes on and on and on
the costs that are associated with
running a legitimate business are way
more than they are running in a
legitimate business
marijuana is now legal
and then came proposition 64 cracking
open the legal playing field to include
adult recreational use
cannabis was now fully legal in
California
[Music]
Americans now live in a state without
marijuana prohibition
[Applause]
[Music]
for many it was the next logical step
though a troubled one everything changed
when we saw the implementation of prop
64 which has really been an unmitigated
disaster and there's three main reasons
the first is over taxation
the second is over regulation and the
third is a complete failure to integrate
the Legacy cannabis Market into the
legal Market it's unfortunate that in
one of the biggest economies in the
world that that learning curve has been
so steep in terms of what not to do when
it comes to things like business
licensing and placing regulatory burdens
on them
it's very interesting to see what's
happening now with cannabis regulation
across the country because the states
actually really are functioning as
Laboratories of democracy
as public opinions shift and more voters
engage in legalization efforts States
like New York are building on
California's example by including social
justice in the conversation from the
very start
we'll work with the state to legalize
marijuana the right way by expunging
arrest records
New York entered the Cannabis space very
intentionally in a way to try to avoid
many of these problems and also with a
very clear focus on empowering
disenfranchised communities and
repairing the harms caused by
prohibition they did so very
intentionally and are moving forward
with those values and focuses in mind
all I can think of right now is pizza
because New York is such a big Stadium
because it's an East Coast State people
are going to be watching it very closely
to see how effective that intentionality
ends up being and making sure the
Grassroots not the big corporations run
this new business
[Applause]
California's prop 64 may be seen as a
cautionary tale for other state
lawmakers Greenhouse is here but for
California's Growers the struggle to
grow a profitable business continues
I have been living and breathing
cannabis since I was in Middle School
and High School on the traditional side
I started at Harborside in 2008 and I
worked there for about 13 years before I
decided that farming was really where I
was going to go
Danny's passion brought her to agris
farms in California's Sacramento Valley
so here at agris we cultivate around
eight to ten thousand pounds roughly and
that's a flowered material ready to go
yolokani makes it so that we are capped
at one acre I cannot grow above an acre
which then limits me to a kind of more
of a smallish farm and I'm unable to
compete with a larger MSO farms in the
big farms that are producing forty
thousand pounds a year if not more
MSO means multi-state operator
larger Farms owned by larger companies
acres farms grows a craft cannabis
meaning it is a small batch producer
emphasizing growing technique and
genetics with extreme daily attention
foreign
each cannabis variety is chosen by Danny
there's a lot of different strains for
me it's really important to be on top of
what the market wants
that is one of the criteria that I look
at of what I'm bringing in genetics to
the farm
the best genetics in the world won't
matter
if no one is buying
the fact that the customer is paying
anywhere between 20 to 36 percent in tax
what other industry do you pay for that
I mean alcohol is not taxed that way
cigarettes are not taxed that way that's
going to push everything back to the
black market to the traditional market
and that's what we're dealing with right
now is over regulation over Taxation and
it's killing anyone that has a legal
license and that's trying to at least do
this correctly
cannabis grower licensed or unlicensed
doesn't have access to the federal
subsidies of a traditional Farm
unless they are growing hemp
and then there's old-fashioned
capitalism
once federalization happens once Federal
Banking goes over now we've got the real
big money for the green Rush right now
we've got multi-state operators they're
big they're not money money
that money will come in and we don't
have access to that money so for us it's
survival
I just hope that there's a place for us
Legacy and small craft people once that
happens
drafting State and National laws if
prohibition is lifted will be
complicated
many states are looking at California
and trying to see what not to do and
what they can do better so that they
don't kind of find themselves in the
spot that we're in 10 years from now
anticipating the end of federal
prohibition
one company in particular took an
unprecedented gamble nearly a decade ago
in 2013 Scott's Miracle Grow a
multi-billion dollar publicly traded
company began their first investments in
cannabis cultivation
through their subsidiary Hawthorne
gardening company
my father Jim was asked a question would
you consider getting into the sort of
emerging cannabis industry and what you
said then in a again in a public
interview which was not something the
board wanted to hear was absolutely
people-grown plants we are in the
business of helping people grow plants
why would we not
but as a U.S company they had a problem
because of conflicting state and federal
laws existing Miracle-Gro research
facilities can only grow proxy crops
such as Tomatoes or hemp which only
simulates marijuana to a point
the solution
open a research facility in Canada
the point for building the facility up
here is that in Canada because it's
completely legal recreationally and
medicinally they were able to start
doing that research up here there's a
lot of similarities between hemp and THC
but being able to actually work with the
THC plants is obviously much more
representative
we figured look let's start Hawthorne
off as kind of an incubator within the
larger company and try to focus on
things that we just for whatever reason
aren't doing well and see if we can get
them up to speed
that focus is Hydroponics a
Horticultural method without soil that
grows crops directly in nutrient-rich
water often using highly controlled
lighting indoors
the researchers test lighting and
nutrients driving growth to the THC Rich
flower
levels are measured
and the work is repeated
we would never launch a tomato food in
every Home Depot in the country if we
hadn't tested it extensively on tomatoes
make sure it works right that's exactly
what we were doing in Hawthorne it's
what we were forced to do because we
can't grow cannabis here in the U.S as a
publicly traded company
it's just one of the many challenges
facing the U.S cannabis industry
and then there's the financing
only a few hundred Banks and Credit
Unions will work with a cannabis
business
[Music]
when you don't have that availability of
capital that means that in particular
small businesses or traditionally
disenfranchised communities are unable
to really get a solid foothold in the
industry a vast majority of the Cannabis
industry is unbanked and some of them
are forced to operate entirely in cash
which makes them targets for criminals
sometimes it's impossible for them to
find payroll companies if they don't
have a paper trail for their income
employees won't be able to get house
loans or car loans or things like that
so there's a huge trickle-down effect
Banking and Taxation are the two
Financial issues that challenge the
industry
cannabis right now is taxed under the
280e tax code which basically says if
you're a federally illegal business
you're a criminal but you're making a
profit you still owe federal income tax
it goes all the way back to Al Capone
and how they nailed him on tax evasion a
business like Hawthorne we deduct
everything a normal business would
payroll rent insurance so on and so
forth and that gets us to a an effective
tax rate between 25 and 30 percent like
most businesses
cannabis businesses because they can't
deduct those expenses which means
they're paying about 80 percent of their
revenue to taxes
which basically means you can't make
money even if you have what should
otherwise be a really profitable
business the single biggest beneficiary
here is the IRS it's clear now after
Decades of evidence that the federal
cannabis prohibition has failed
anything that has been illegal and
vilified for as long as cannabis will
have victims left in its way
both Financial
and Criminal
some of these occur under state law and
some of these occur under federal law
there's really a whole constellation of
policies that punish people for using a
substance that's safer than alcohol we
have to as a society make an attempt to
make up for and repair those Harms
as many states change their marijuana
laws getting cannabis offenders out of
jail and Records expunged has become a
priority for activists
[Music]
Steve D'Angelo now takes his activism to
Washington D.C
I stepped down as CEO of Harborside
and launched an organization called the
last prisoner project in 2019 we worked
to get prisoners released at one time I
didn't think I was going to ever you
know
we are dedicated to making sure that as
we build this legal industry around the
world that we also make sure that people
who are in prison for doing exactly the
same thing are not left out and are
given an opportunity to rebuild their
lives
in 2022 the U.S House of Representatives
passed the marijuana opportunity
reinvestment and expungement Act
more designed to end Federal prohibition
and lay the groundwork to erase criminal
records for cannabis offenses
the sweeping bill would have removed
marijuana from the Controlled Substances
Act and started a process to expunge
cannabis convictions
to right the wrongs of the failed War on
Drugs
you would think that when a society
decides that the thing that used to be
illegal is now going to be legal that we
would stop punishing people for the
thing that's not wrong anymore I'm not
looking to be a torture Reuben Lindo is
also passionate about prison reform
especially former convicts caught up in
the penal system for non-violent drug
offenses
we're going to start to learn what the
impacts were generationally in this
failed War on Drugs just by helping
people get their records expunged I'm
not talking about all drugs are good I'm
just talking about specifically the
green plant cannabis think about this a
17 year old kid in 2014 gets arrested
for unlawful possession of marijuana
which is a violation of a penal code
takes a conviction on that or even a no
contest his family can no longer live in
public housing he's not eligible for tap
and Pell Grants to go to college
wait a minute wait wait so you're
telling me a kid who got caught with
weed can't go to college
thousands of men and women remain
incarcerated on marijuana related
charges
users Growers and dealers alike
[Music]
on October 6 2022
President Biden took a step toward his
campaign promise to decriminalize
marijuana
I'm announcing a pardon for all prior
Federal offenses for the simple
possession of marijuana I'm calling on
all governors to do the same for State
marijuana possession offenses some
cannabis activists say that this is a
step in the right direction that we
right these wrongs no one should be in
jail just for using or possessing
marijuana
still many say the policy and the
president don't go far enough
[Applause]
I'm here today because it's important
that we get our friends or family our
comrades out of jail for cannabis
offenses I'm here today to voice the
frustration
[Music]
thank you
and demand the release
of the thousands still in prison still
with records withheld access to
opportunity and basic human rights
suffering from Cannabis prohibition
public wants real we don't want fake
we don't want no malarkey
the president was very clear he was
explicit he said it in a nationally
televised debate speaking directly to
voters everybody gets out records
expunged he didn't qualify it he didn't
say it applied only to simple possession
and we want the president to keep his
promise
[Music]
the president can free Federal cannabis
prisoners
but tens of thousands remain jailed by
States and municipalities
today you look at some of my friends who
are getting out of prison that would not
have happened if States like Illinois
and New York which have past cannabis
legalization not by initiative but by
the state legislatures this is primarily
an issue of justice and freedom freedom
to be able to consume relatively
non-toxic plant in the privacy and
safety of your own home
when you look at it through this lens
then you start to see what is most
important about the efforts to legalize
cannabis money and tax revenue and
creating jobs and opportunity those are
wonderful additions to it
but at very base this is about Justice
and personal freedom
[Music]
thank you